et notre invité politique ce matin
c'était la nageoire bonjour mais rejoue
donc battre avec nos ministres chargés
du logement candidate aux législatives
dans le val-de-marne et vous présidez le
conseil national de territoire de
progresser le mouvement qui représente
l'ailé gauche de la majorité on va bien
sûr parler de toutes ces questions on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice veysseyre au nom du groupe ebra
bonjour février bonjour orione le groupe
ebra on le répète plus ce sont les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
comment un mot sur l'ukraine emmanuelle
wargon évidemment avant de parler des
questions nationales l'ukraine ou si on
est en 75e jours de guerre aujourd'hui
avec évidemment des dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés qui ont dû quitter le pays
combien de réfugiés et craignant sont
actuellement hébergés en france alors le
nombre de réfugiés ukrainiens qui sont
arrivés en france et environ 75000
personnes qu'on a enregistrées dans les
passages frontières mais tous ne reste
pas en france que la france est parfois
un pays de transit donc on a accordé en
fait à peu près 50 mille titres de
séjour temporaire vous savez les
autorisations de séjour de protection
spéciale et nous hébergeons en gros 30
mille personnes
les autres ça veut dire qu'ils ont
trouvé un accueil directement dans leur
famille ou dans leur propre réseau
d'amis et enfin ils ont ces trente mille
personnes dans des structures de l'état
là où on chez des particuliers en fête
ses trente mille personnes dans des
structures piloté par l'état qui sont
soit des hébergements collectifs type
hôtels ou campings ou autres soient de
l'hébergement citoyens ou des logements
que des collectivités ont pu mettre à
disposition et en gros 13 mille enfants
sont scolarisés voilà donc ça vous donne
une idée du nombre de personnes qu'on
accueille la france n'est pas le premier
pays d'accueil parce qu'évidemment on
est un peu loin de l'ukraine et donc les
réfugiés sont d'abord dans les premiers
pays
mitrow de l'udc vous en attendez
d'autres réfugiés dans les prochains
jours n'a évidemment difficile à dire ça
a commencé fort maintenant on ça ça le
nombre d'arrivées est un petit peu plus
limité jour après jour donc on n'est pas
dans une progression très très forte
mais on est en capacité et je voudrais
de nouveau salué l'élan de solidarité
parce que sur la plateforme internet
pour l'accueil des ukrainiens on a plus
de cinquante mille propositions
d'hébergement citoyens donc ça veut dire
qu'on a encore des possibilités et que
l'état aujourd'hui encore combien de
place pour les petits on avait identifié
70000 80000 places donc voyez on a de la
marge par rapport aux 30000 que nous
accueillons aujourd'hui après tout notre
enjeu c'est de ne pas laisser les gens
trop longtemps dans des structures
temporaires type hôtel mobil-home ou
autre ou centre de vacances d'abord
parce que les hôtels les centres de
vacances ont vocation à accueillir des
vacanciers cet été et ensuite parce que
une famille ukrainienne est mieux dans
un vrai logement quand on a une
structure temporaire et donc nous
continuons à travailler pour permettre à
ces personnes de passer du temporaire a
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus stable
de type logement une dernière question
là tu y es ce que vous avez une idée du
montant des aides de l'état pour
l'hébergement de ces réfugiés craignant
depuis le début du conflit alors on n'a
pas encore consolidée tous les chiffres
d'autant plus que le premier accueil et
sous la responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur donc c'est pas le budget du
ministère du logement mais ça reste
évidemment le budget de l'état de notre
côté on finance les aides au logement on
finance les associations qui font de
l'intermédiation locative
ce sera quelques centaines de millions
d'euros mais on n'a pas de chiffres
précis on va parler de d'emmanuel mâcon
emmanuel macron kane est officiellement
investi samedi vous y étiez d'ailleurs
dû rentrer dans son discours il s'est
défini comme un président nouveau avec
une méthode nouvelle cela veut dire que
la méthode du quinquennat macro n'était
pas la bonne je crois qu'il a dit
quelque chose de très fort qui est ça
n'est pas la prolongation du mandat
précédent c'est un nouveau mandat qui
commence il a dit d'ailleurs avec des
français qui sont eux-mêmes différent de
ce qu'il était il ya cinq ans je crois
que le président est très attaché
maintenant avoir une méthode de
gouvernement
qu'ils soient là plus associatif
possible qui associe le plus possible
les français les corps constitués il est
il reconnaît que parfois il a peut-être
voulu aller un peu vite au début du
quinquennat précédent et qu'il faut
travailler avec chacun bien sûr avec les
français et avec tous ceux qui les
représentent donc ça s'exprimera très
vénérés on peut hélas pas assez consulté
les syndicats les élus locaux également
l'enfant première c'est vrai que le
quinquennat a été marqué on le sait tous
par beaucoup de crises et les choses ont
évolué et déjà en cours de quinquennat
avec le grand débat national que moi
j'ai eu l'honneur de copiloter et avec
un travail avec les élus locaux avec
lesquels on s'est beaucoup rapproché
tout au long du quinquennat donc l'idée
c'est d'aller encore un cran plus loin
il le fera sur les retraites sur la
refondation de l'école sur la question
de la santé et notamment la lutte contre
les déserts médicaux donc voilà
l'intention du président est très claire
il l'a exprimé en tant que candidat et
c'était très important qu'il exprime en
tant que président réinvesti voir
revenir sur la réforme des retraites
dans un instant mais un dernier mot sur
ce qui s'est passé samedi vous avez
entendu laurent fabius le président du
conseil constitutionnel par les dents
malaise démocratique préoccupant le
président s'est engagé à une renaissance
démocratique dont le pays a besoin par
quoi doit passer cette renaissance
démocratique et je vous dis par un
travail probablement qui laisse le temps
de la concertation de la consultation
sur les grandes réformes et puis vous
savez que le président s'est aussi
engagé à mettre en place une commission
transpartisane sur la réforme des
institutions
la réforme des institutions avait été
envisagé dans le premier quinquennat
elle n'était pas allée au bout et là
l'idée c'est de travailler directement
avec les partis politiques du pays pour
regarder si un consensus est possible
sur les grandes lignes avant ensuite de
pouvoir écrire un texte qui forcément
passera à l'assemblée et au sénat frais
sur les fractures parce qu'on a vu
emmanuel macron 2017 s'était engagé à
résorber les fractures du pays or on l'a
vu en 2000 2 les fractures elles sont
toujours aussi grandes si ce n'est plus
grande qu'en 2017 comment vous les
résorber cette fracture territoriale ses
fractures sociales ont les résorbe je
pense d'abord en essayant d'apporter des
réponses les plus concrètes possible aux
préoccupations des français là
évidemment le sujet du moment c'est le
pouvoir d'achat vous avez vu bruno le
maire consultant ce moment et c'est très
important c'est aussi ce dont on parlait
il ya cinq minutes l'école la santé oms
les réseaux bosse dans cette nouvelle
méthode de gouvernance en prenant le
temps d'écouter et puis après les
fractures ont été forte pendant ce
quinquennat parce que les crises ont été
forte aussi bien sûr que la crise
sanitaire avec les décisions qu'il a
fallu prendre qui étaient des décisions
parfois difficiles qu'ils étaient des
décisions dans lesquels voilà on a
restreint en notre capacité à tout ça
allait venir ça a forcément aussi créé
des fractures et c'est uniquement les
crises mme ce sont aussi les réformes la
politique d' emmanuel macron qui a donné
le sentiment certains français de ne pas
être écoutés que le gouvernement ne
s'occupait pas deux le pense qu'il y a
depuis très longtemps un sentiment
croissant auprès des français que la
politique est trop déconnectés de leurs
besoins que les hommes et les femmes
politiques ne les comprennent pas ne
répondent pas à ce qu'ils vivent et
d'une certaine manière vive entre eux je
ne crois pas que ce soit né dans le
premier quinquennat d' emmanuel macron
je pense que ça vient de très loin en
réalité est que c'est probablement à
nous de trouver une manière de
réinventer la politique de réinventer le
lien entre les hommes et les femmes
politiques et les français que vous
restiez de green blé on a fait ses
exercices de démocratie directe pendant
ce quinquennat qui ont été pour partie
réussie et pour partie inachevée mais je
voudrais juste dire un mot du grand
débat national parce que j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps on a en réalité pris
beaucoup de décisions est appliquée
beaucoup de mesures issues de ce qui
s'est dit dans le grand débat par
exemple la générale est la
généralisation des maisons france
services par exemple l'augmentation
massive de la prime d'activité par
exemple le fait de dire désormais on ne
fermera plus une classe sans demander
son avis au maire donc en fait on l'a
fait mais on l'a pas bien raconter et
donc on les français pensent pour une
partie d'entre eux que ce grand débat a
été un moment de
respiration démocratique mais qu'il n'en
est pas sorti de décision alors que des
décisions en sont sortis et donc il faut
qu'on retravaille la manière dont on
pilote ces exercices non seulement quand
on va à la rencontre des français dans
ce type de démocratie directe mais
ensuite de savoir comment est-ce qu'on
en tire des conséquences et comment
est-ce qu'on en rencontre d'une certaine
manière sur le plan de relance on a bien
raconter ce qu'on faisait avec le plan
de relance et france relance sur le
grand débat on n'a pas vraiment raconter
ce qu on en tirait ou en tout cas pas
assez donc je pense qu'on a démarré des
choses y compris issus de crise et que
nous avons besoin pendant ce quinquennat
d'inventer encore de nouvelles formes et
puis surtout de trouver la place de ces
formes de démocratie plus directe par
rapport à la démocratie représentative
en a parlé du pouvoir d'achat
préoccupation majeure des français avec
une inflation à 5 % le gouvernement qui
va recevoir les associations de
consommateurs cette semaine et notamment
celles qui s'intéressent au logement un
ministère que vous connaissez bien
comment
vous venez à il ya cinq ans une mesure
hautement symbolique était la réduction
de 5 euros des appels qui a donné
d'ailleurs un coup d'envoi aux insoumis
1 contre le gouvernement est-ce qu'il
faut revenir contre cette mesure ça fait
partie des ça fait partie des demandes
de certaines associations de
consommateurs en fait on a redistribué
beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat dans le
quinquennat précédent après cette mesure
apl d'abord on a fait la réforme qu'on
appelle appel en temps réel qui permet
d'ajuster plus vite les apl à son niveau
de revenu et puis ensuite on a
redistribué je vous le disais à la fois
avec la prime d'activités pour tous ceux
qui travaillent à la fois pour les
étudiants avec la suppression de la
sécurité sociale étudiante pense que
l'étape d'après et c'est l'une des très
belles mesures du programme du candidat
maintenant président c'est la solidarité
à la source parce que ça consiste à
revoir les différents barèmes des
prestations et à faciliter le fait que
chacun ait accès à toutes les
prestations auxquelles il ou elle a le
droit vous savez qu'il ya une quinzaine
de prestations sociales les aides au
logement font partie il y en a plein
d'autres et 15 prestations égales 15
formulaire de demande égale 15 manière
différente de calculer le revenu qui va
vous permettre d'y avoir droit ou pas la
composition familiale la date à laquelle
on regarde tout ça donc cette solidarité
à la source qui va simplifier qui va
permettre de faire une demande et
ensuite d'avoir un versement automatique
c'est je pense une bonne réponse donc la
réponse 5 euros ce
à l'intérieur de cette réforme on pourra
regarder de nouveau les barèmes mais je
pense qu'il faut y aller plus
globalement autre question toujours
liées au logement liées à l'inflation
est la hausse des taux notamment pour
les crédits immobiliers dont les taux
ont augmenté une grosse brute de 0 5%
depuis le début de l'année les revenus
modestes sont les premiers impactés que
peut faire l'état ce n'est pas fini
manifestement cette hausse ce qui est
sûr c'est que le logement c'est bien le
premier poste de dépenses des ménages
dont contrats très significatifs que ce
soit quand vous rembourser un emprunt
immobilier où que ce soit quand vous
payez votre loyer sur les taux ou on
regarde ça aussi avec bruno le maire de
façon très rapprochée pour l'instant on
n'a pas eu une explosion du montant des
des taux immobiliers mais bien sûr on
surveille il ya toujours un effet de
vases communicants entre les taux et les
prix puisque dans la période dans
laquelle les taux d'intérêt étaient très
bas en fait les prix eux mêmes de
l'immobilier a beaucoup monté ce qu'il
faut regarder c'est le pouvoir
d'investissement qui mélangent en fait
l'évolution du prix et le taux auquel
vous vous entendez par là les prix des
logements vont baisser les prix des
logements ont plutôt en tout cas dans
les zones dans lesquelles les prix sont
les plus élevés sont plutôt en train de
se stabiliser ils sont ils ont été très
dynamiques plutôt dans les villes
moyennes dans les villes de province on
est en train de regarder comment tout ça
évolue donc en fait ce que je veux dire
c'est que il faut analyser à la fois
l'évolution des taux et l'évolution des
prix et ensuite il ya pour l'instant une
aide qui est le prêt à taux zéro et on
s'est dit que le prêt à taux zéro qui
est moins intéressant quand les taux
sont bas on pouvait probablement essayer
de le faire évoluer vers autre chose
donc voilà ça fera partie vous allez là
sur ces nouvelles mesures en tout cas on
va réfléchir
sur des mesures pour qu'elle soit
cohérente par rapport aux besoins des
français et ce à partir de quand très
vite nouveau gouvernement quand il sera
en place s'affrontent en réalisant les
meilleures semaines de ceux de ce
nouveau gouvernement justement puisqu'on
parle de calendrier et de tempe alors il
ya eu de l'immobilier mais vous voyez
les français ils ont du mal à faire
leurs courses ils ont du mal à faire
leur plein d'essence emmanuel macron
promet une loi exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat mais seulement elle était est-ce
que c'est pas trop de parisse cap à des
mesures à prendre avant l'été ça arrive
bientôt quand même et c'est important
d'avoir une première loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur dans laquelle on aura la
réindexation tr retraite sur l'inflation
dans laquelle on aura le résultat de la
négociation sur l'évolution du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires et d'autres
mesures de pouvoir d'achat si nécessaire
à commencer par la prolongation du
bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz et
l'électricité vous savez qu'on est le
seul pays à le faire en europe et qu'on
protège vraiment très fortement le
budget des ménages en ayant bloqué le
prix du gaz est l'augmentation du prix
de l'électricité donc tout ça ça va
arriver très vite et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il faut de nouveaux députés dans la
campagne législative parce qu'il faut
des députés avec une majorité pour le
président de la république pour pouvoir
voter tout ça et on va en parler mais
d'abord un mot sur la réforme des
retraites la retraite à 65 ans vous
estimez que la mesure proposée par jean
luc mélenchon la retraite à 60 ans n'est
pas finançable vous pensez que la
retraite à 65 ans
c'est un passage obligé d'abord la
proposition de cette alliance qui
s'appelle nubes ou nuls savait que moi
j'appelle dupe parce que je pense qu'il
n'y a rien derrière c'est une
proposition qui revient à la retraite à
60 ans sans qu'on sache très bien avec
combien d'annuités donc qui en réalité
nous y 40 alors qu'aujourd'hui on est
déjà à quarante deux et qu'on est en
train d'augmenter progressivement donc
c'est une proposition qui accroîtrait
très massivement le déficit de nos
régimes de retraite et oui j'assume tout
à fait de dire qu'elle est démagogique
et pas finançable de notre côté ce que
le président souhaite et là aussi les
sera largement la place à la
concertation c'est d'assurer les
équilibres de moyen long terme du régime
des retraites avec le maintien de la
répartition ce qui veut dire
probablement travailler un peu plus
longtemps en n'utilisant pour ça le
l'outil de l'âge légal mais cette
discussion va avoir lieu et ça va avec
ce qu'en disait au début une volonté de
tendre la main et de prendre le temps de
discuter donc je préjuge pas du tout
apprécié le temps référendum sur cette
question c'est ce que dit notamment
françois bayrou attendons déjà de voir
comment les discussions on tourne et si
finalement on arrive à un point qui est
considérée comme un point de compromis
positif donc pas forcément a forcément
en revanche il faut prendre le temps de
discuter avec les acteurs vous êtes une
femme de gauche on le rappelle vous
assumez pleinement le fait aujourd'hui
de dire que on prête de gauche et appelé
les français à travailler plus et plus
tard en fait le travail c'est une valeur
autant de droite que de gauche et c est
quand même historiquement vraiment une
valeur de gauche est l'un des éléments
dont moi je suis le plus fier
collectivement du bilan de ce
quinquennat c'est la baisse du chômage
parce que l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat ça commence par la baisse du
chômage ça commence par le fait d'avoir
plus de français qui ont un emploi de
qualité qui leur permet de bien vivre de
leurs salaires un chômage qui est passé
de 10 % à 7 % c'est évidemment une
augmentation massive du pouvoir d'achat
et donc oui on a besoin de continuer à
travailler dans ce pays à la fois
pendant toute la vie active et donc
c'est pour ça que le président vise le
plein emploi et viser le plein emploi ça
veut dire plus de formation
professionnelle plus d'insertion
professionnelle la capacité à les
accompagner ceux qui sont le plus
éloignés aujourd'hui du marché du
travail et répondre aux besoins des
entreprises qui n'arrivent pas à
embaucher et ça veut dire aussi
probablement sur une vie professionnelle
travailler plus longtemps sauf dans les
cas de deux carrières pénibles et c'est
ça aussi sur lequel il faut qu'on rouvre
la discussion le président l'a dit la
question de la pénibilité comment est ce
qu'on la prend en compte pour garder une
justice sociale qui fait que c'est pas
la même chose de travailler pendant
toute sa vie professionnelle dans un
bureau ou dans le secteur du bâtiment
évidemment sur des chantiers ça c'est un
sujet qu'il faut qu'on retrouve à
l'intérieur de sa vie sur cette question
de la gauche parce qu'on a beaucoup
entendu emmanuel macron dans
l'entre-deux-tours se tourner vers les
électeurs de gauche avec un certain
nombre de propositions notamment sur
l'écologie pour peut-être attirer à lui
un ses électeurs dans le cadre du second
tour est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous qui
représentez la jambe gauche de la
majorité vous avez l'impression d'être
assez entendue au sein de la macro ni
est d'abord on voit bien dans ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui qu'il y a deux gauches
irréconciliables jean luc mélenchon dit
le contraire mais c'est pas vrai il y à
la gauche qui se compromet dans cette
alliance avec l'extrême gauche de l
échiquier puis il ya la gauche qui garde
ses valeurs rocard disent les valeurs de
jacques delors qu'est la gauche sociale
démocrate qui elle est en réalité très
près d' emmanuel macron donc ses
intérêts les socialistes qui dénoncent
l'accord qui dénonce la nuque vous les
appelez à vous rejoindre
rich nous ils ont toute leur place dans
une coalition de progrès et dans une
réflexion avec les hommes et les femmes
de bonne volonté qui travaillent autour
du président on a en réalité des valeurs
qui sont extrêmement proches évidemment
je discuterai régulièrement avec
françois rebsamen par exemple et moi
j'invite tous les schémas voulu
rejoindre territoire de progrès pourquoi
mais en fait la question de
l'organisation de la majorité est une
question qui est une question politique
qui va se réouvrir avec la création du
parti renaissance et qui sera l'occasion
aussi de regarder comment tout ça se
structure mais en tout cas sur le plan
des idées des valeurs du combat
politique parce qu'on fait de la
politique pour défendre ses idées on
fait de la politique parce qu'on veut
améliorer les choses et on veut les
améliorer avec une vision politique du
pays sur le plan des valeurs et des
idées cette gauche c'est une gauche qui
en fait se ressemblent beaucoup c'est
une gauche c'est effectivement qui est
attaché à la valeur travail qui attachés
à l équilibre des comptes néanmoins qui
pensent qu'il faut à la fois produire et
redistribue qui est attachée à la
justice sociale à l'idéal européen
cette gauche là elle a beaucoup de
choses à faire ensemble et je pense que
nous aurons ces discussions sur le fond
mais aujourd'hui vous appelez françois
hollande bernard cazeneuve à vous
rejoindre à travailler avec vous moi
j'appelle
un art cazeneuve en particulier pour qui
j'ai beaucoup de respect et gta s'est
indigné de voir comment je crois que
c'est alexis corbière qu'il a qualifiée
dans l'auge parlante j'ai trouvé ça
scandaleux attention il a dit celle des
s'affrontant de plus que le départ de
will attendant le paiement sécurisé
c'est quand même c'est quand même
vraiment une marque de mépris donc oui
on dit bernard cazeneuve mais pour
françois hollande bernard cazeneuve
françois hollande tous ceux qui qui en
vitre de travailler à une refondation à
faire vivre ces valeurs je pense que
c'est important que ce dialogue ait lieu
un malade mais
là on a vu une photo tout à l'heure où
on voyait edouard philippe richard
ferrand françois bayrou
le pré le patron de l'hôpital voilà
le cadre interne là dans cette équipe la
social-démocratie peau alors d'abord ce
qu'on ne voit pas sur cette photo c'est
qu'avec barbara pompili nous étions au
premier rang lors de cette conférence de
presse à bages allez vous le dire ça
manque un peu de m'engager dans cette
rue georges je suis d'accord mais en
fait on était juste à côté et après je
pense que ce soit richard ferrand qui
rappelait à cette occasion qu'il avait
été membre du parti socialiste pendant
g3 je crois 40 ans au stanislas guérini
voilà ce sont des personnalités qui
porte ces valeurs mais il n'ya pas d'un
contrario c'est à dire on on a fait le
choix collectivement de travailler
ensemble d'edouard philippe à richard
ferrand avec françois perrault et
stanislas guérini pour le pays et ses
sensibilités elle s'exprime au sein
d'une majorité qui a montré qu'elle
était prête à gouverner prête à
gouverner c'est à dire prêtes à
affronter la réalité
et moi je me retrouve tout à fait dans
cette majorité territoire de progrès
aussi après en ce qui concerne la
structuration de tout ça mais territoire
d'un chantier cédant ensemble parce que
pourquoi vous n'étiez pas aux côtés des
bandas c'est pas moi qui fais la
scénarisation et l'organisation et les
photos mais en tout cas on sera
évidemment dans cette majorité mais au
maire au même titre que qu'horizon comme
madame oui on sera en fête
la refondation de la république en
marche dans la création de ce nouveau
parti qui va s'appeler renaissance qui
sera l'occasion de se structurer il la
participation de la gauche à cette
majorité il faut en premier ministre de
gauche
il faut un premier ministre qui incarne
la jambe droite et la jambe gauche et le
dépassement et si vous voulez j'ai
travaillé avec edouard philippe j'ai eu
la chance d'être dans son gouvernement
et avec jean castex jean castex a une
sensibilité sociale très forte il est
issu de la droite mais en réalité il a
beaucoup soutenu le logement
l'hébergement d'urgence et c'est donc au
delà des étiquettes il faut quelqu'un
qui porte cette sensibilité et
évidemment il faut que ces deux
sensibilités la sensibilité centre droit
et centre gauche soit bien représentée
et je pense qu'elle le sera de toute
façon dont la composition du
gouvernement aujourd'hui vous critiquer
cette alliance la nuque cette nouvelle
formation que vous appelez du que ça
veut dire que l vous inquiète que vous
êtes inquiet sur le fait que votre
majorité
puisque chaque circonscription compte
chaque sièges de députés aux
législatives compte et qu'on a
absolument besoin d'avoir une majorité
claire pour le président de la
république jean luc mélenchon a déjà
perdu trois fois la présidentielle il
l'a perdu au premier tour cette fois-ci
il essaye de nous faire croire qu'en
réalité il l'a gagné il l'a perdu
néanmoins cette alliance qui pour moi
est une alliance démagogique qui est qui
et sur un projet de fonds qui ne tient
pas la route cette alliance elle ce sera
une proposition politique nouvelle et
donc moi je pense que nous devons faire
une campagne très énergiques pour dire
aux électeurs aux français qu'il ya un
vrai choix politique à faire et que donc
cette élection est importante mais c'est
votre adversaire aujourd'hui dans cette
campagne des législatives jean luc
mélenchon c'est l'adversaire de la
majorité en tous cas c'est celui des
ventes en plus on vous entend plus
parler du rassemblement national
l'impression que c'est haro sur jean luc
mélenchon de la partie en effet le
rassemblement national a été battu au
deuxième tour et donc en fait comme vous
le savez en général on fait plutôt des
campagnes positif dans lesquels on
propose un projet plutôt forcément que
d'être en négatif sur nos adversaires
mais en tout cas celui qui se positionne
donne la berge comme l'adversaire
principal c'est jean luc mélenchon il
faut pas sous-estimer le risque pour le
pays si cette coalition avait une
majorité je ne crois pas que cela se
produira mais encore une fois chaque ça
c'est quoi le risque pourquoi il ya un
risque si jamais jean luc mélenchon
parce que je considère que son programme
qui est en réalité anti européen qui
n'est pas claire sur le plan
international et j'étais face à manon
aubry dans un débat elle veut toujours
sortir de l'otan donc c'est qu'on
considère que son programme est un
programme qui porte beaucoup de risques
pour le mot dans la bouche des manuels
macro et dans la bouche de jean luc
mélenchon c'est le mot colère est-ce que
vous la comprenez cette colère en tout
cas moi je l'entends pour avoir fait
beaucoup de terrains pendant la campagne
présidentielle et pour en faire
maintenant beaucoup dans la campagne
législative
ce sentiment d'être mal représentés ou
malentendu est un sentiment auquel il
faut qu'on va sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille c'est très dangereux
démocratiquement qu'une partie des
français se sentent délaissés par la
houle est politique donc le fait d'aller
à la rencontre
le fait d'écouter tous les français le
fait de construire avec eux et pas
seulement dans les grandes villes
c'est vraiment indispensable
c'est évidemment un risque démocratique
majeur que de laisser une partie du pays
pensé qu' il a été ils ont été il ou
elle délaissé par la politique qui ne
s'intéresse pas à eux et c'est vrai
pendant les campagnes
c'est très important de continuer après
les élections pour ne pas donner
l'impression que au moment des zélés des
élections vous voyez passer tous les
candidats qui s'intéressent à vous et
puis juste après les élections ils
disparaissent du paysage et donc c'est
l'exercice des mandats politiques c'est
ce que j'ai fait en tant que ministre du
logement beaucoup beaucoup de terrain
beaucoup beaucoup de déplacements pour
aller à la rencontre des français par
exemple sur ma prime rénove si ça marche
c'est aussi parce que je suis allé
beaucoup écouter les gens et c'est ce
que je ferais si je suis élu député
merci beaucoup merci l'argon d'avoir été
notre invité merci à brice
[Musique]